(music playing)
So Android Wear is here, and you
can't wait to use its sensors.
You're going to do everything
from analyzing karate punches
to rating epic guitar solos.
But if your watch runs out of battery,
none of that will happen.
I'm Lisa Wray, and using the sensors
properly in Android Wear
will keep your app up and running.
Let's sum up the best practices
for sensors on Android Wear.
Ask for updates as
infrequently as possible.
That means unregistering your
listener when you don't need data,
using a low delivery rate,
and bashing sensor data.
Leverage your paired phone.
Do processing on the phone using
the phone sensors, if possible.
Ready? Let's see how it's done.
First, take advantage of the platform.
Don't calculate steps
yourself for movement.
The watch has a hardware step sensor
optimized for minimal battery use.
And instead of making your own,
use Android's built-in activity
recognition framework.
Next, only use the sensors
when you need them.
Don't leave your watch app
listening to the step sensor all day.
Unregister your listener after
the user finishes their run.
You should also only ask for updates
as frequently as you need them.
This is called the delivery rate.
And some sensors are capable of
delivering updates extremely frequently.
Getting data delivered many times a second
makes sense for a game
using the accelerometer,
but not for the pedometer.
People only make steps
once or twice a second.
The next level is sensor event batching.
You decide the frequency
of data collection.
You decide the size of a batch.
And you can request immediate
delivery of events even between batches.
So for example, a running app
can request large batches
of step events to save battery.
But if the user turns their wrist
and activates the screen,
you can immediately get
an updated step count.
The final thing to remember
about your watch is that
it's guaranteed to be paired to a larger,
more powerful phone with a bigger battery.
So whenever possible,
take advantage of the phone.
If you need to do any computation
or processing on watch sensor data,
send that data to your phone
and process it there.
And while you're
transferring data, remember,
batching isn't just for sensor updates.
And there's one more way to use your
phone to take the load off the watch.
Use the phone sensors.
The watch sensors are great
for hand movement,
but if you need general motion, switch
to the phone's accelerometer instead.
The phone's battery can take it.
You can access and use the sensor
frameworks on Android Wear
just like on any other Android phone.
And for more information and tips
on sensors and sensor batching,
check out this DevByte
I recorded last year.
Finally, since Android Wear runs Android,
many other videos
in Android Performance Patterns series
are just as useful to you.
So check out the rest of the material, and
join us on the Wear Devs Google+ community
for tips and advice from other developers.
Thanks for watching.
And remember, Perf Matters.
(music playing)